[Music]
on this sunday night
the uk variant reaches every province
the coronavirus mutation that is more
infectious
and potentially more deadly it will very
soon
become the dominant virus
in canada plus an outbreak in an ontario
community linked to the south african
variant
no laughing matter the supreme court
weighs in on a canadian comedian's joke
about a disabled boy
plus high-tech commerce will canadian
banks put
digital currency into your wallet and
the discovery of a 5 000 year old
brewery
and its role in ancient egypt
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us health officials in every province
have confirmed cases of the highly
transmissible coven 19 variant
first discovered in the united kingdom
there are also cases involving variants
from south africa brazil
and nigeria as david aiken reports there
are concerns about their spread as some
provinces push ahead with
easing restrictions
in the national capital skaters on the
rideau canal are out in force on a
valentine's sunday
ready for covid 19 restrictions to be
lifted
here and in some parts of ontario on
tuesday
in manitoba some of those restrictions
loosened this weekend
gyms and restaurants now open to 25
percent capacity and yet
health experts are worried that premiers
are moving too
quickly you can't cheat laws of nature
through
wishful thinking and that is
unfortunately what doug
ford brian pallister and others jason
kenny
are trying to do in north bay ontario
public health officials say they've
confirmed their first case of the covet
19 variant
first found in south africa that's a
variant for which
current vaccines are not as effective it
has also been found in other ontario
communities
and in bc now imagine something less
controllable with vaccines that is also
more aggressive
at jumping from person to person and
perhaps more deadly when it does jump
and you can see this is not a good track
to be on
in the meantime the b117 variant that's
the one first discovered in the uk
has been found in all 10 provinces
researchers say
it may be up to 70 percent more
infectious
and is more lethal it will very soon in
a matter of weeks or at most
say a month and a half become the
dominant
virus in canada and that in turn has put
even more pressure on canada's
vaccination program
manitoba was so concerned about the
federal government's vaccine rollout
performance
it decided last week to buy directly
from a calgary manufacturer
that may have vaccines ready by the end
of the year but only
after it says it was turned down by
manufacturers
with already approved vaccines we have
tried pfizer we've tried moderna i could
go down the list astrazeneca johnson and
johnson and so on and so forth
they are not allowed by their deal with
the federal government
to sell to the provinces the premiers
and the prime minister are expected to
meet via teleconference later this week
and
domestic vaccine production capacity is
almost sure to top the agenda
david aiken global news ottawa there are
worries a new cluster of kova 19 cases
on a manitoba first nation could be the
variant first identified in the uk
seven probable cases have been detected
on the pangasi first nation in eastern
manitoba
the community has been under a strict
lockdown since february 2nd
last weekend the canadian armed forces
deployed more than a dozen personnel
to provide support samples have been
sent to the national microbiology lab
for genomic sequencing to confirm
whether the cases are in fact
the more contagious uk strain the uk
has reached a significant milestone in
its covet 19 vaccination program
more than 50 million of the country's
most vulnerable people
have received the first dose of the
vaccine the government reached its
target a day early
and less than 10 weeks after the first
shock was administered
roughly 22 percent of britain's
population has been given at least one
shot
the vaccine rollout is now being
expanded to other groups
starting tomorrow new measures come into
effect in britain
uk nationals coming from 33 red list
countries
will have to quarantine in a government
approved hotel the stay will cost the
traveler thousands of dollars
they'll also be forced to cover the
costs of two coveted 19
tests as our europe bureau chief crystal
gamansing explains
anyone caught breaking the new rules
could face jail time this is a sample
room i'm going to take you into now
it's no luxury suite but you will get a
yoga mat in your room at this government
designated
quarantine hotel the most important
thing is the virus killer
which is a machine which is running 24 7
is sucking up the air and cleaning the
air and killing any germs
new restrictions are being imposed on
british nationals
landing in england from 33 countries
mostly in south america and africa
portugal
is the only european location on the
government's red list
other travelers from kobe 19 hot spots
were previously banned
when they arrive they'll be escorted to
a designated hotel
which will be closed to guests who
aren't quarantining for 10 days
or for longer if they test positive for
covid19
during their stay the health secretary
detailed the government's new strategy
in parliament this past week
uk media reports however outlined
concerns from the immigration services
union
saying its members were still unclear on
their role
travelers who don't comply could be hit
with huge fines
and the possibility of up to 10 years
behind bars
we'll be backing this new system with
strong enforcement of both home
quarantine
and hotel quarantine people who flout
these rules
are putting us all at risk england has
been
in lockdown since mid-december the third
so far in this pandemic infection rates
hospitalizations
and deaths are steadily declining but
virus
variants pose an increased threat
in the first wave 0.1 of cases came from
china where we had restrictions 62
percent
came from france and from spain where we
didn't have restrictions
and there's every reason to think that
the variant will behave in the same way
from monday positive covid19 tests from
travelers
will be sent for genomic sequencing a
move that will allow health officials to
watch for new mutations
and give other nations a heads up on
what could be coming to their shores
crystal gomanson global news london
new zealand's largest city has been
ordered into a new
three-day lockdown starting tonight
auckland's 1.7 million residents have to
stay at home
other than for essential work and
groceries that's after three cases of
the uk variant of kova 19 were
identified
new zealand has won widespread praise
for its handling of the pandemic
going months without community
transmission the country has recorded
just over 2 000 cases
and 25 deaths the spread of another
deadly virus is raising concerns in west
africa
the world health organization has
declared an ebola outbreak in
guinea where at least seven people
tested positive for the virus
three of them died it's the first time
ebola has been detected in the country
since 2016
at the end of the deadliest outbreak in
history that epidemic began in guinea
and claimed the lives of more than 11
000 people
across three countries tomorrow the
supreme court of canada is set to hear a
case that pits a quebec comedian
against the subject of one of his jokes
stand-up comic mike ward made fun of a
boy who lives with a rare genetic
disorder
his family then filed a complaint with
the human rights tribunal
and it ruled against ward he's fought
that ruling
all the way to the highest court in the
country mike armstrong has a look at the
arguments and what's at stake
this is comic mike ward telling the joke
that landed him in court
he told it during shows between 2010 and
2013
it was about a boy with a disfigurement
jeremy gabriel singing for the pope
supposedly because he was terminally ill
and then ward basically being
disappointed
because he didn't die now gabriel has
treacher collins syndrome it's a genetic
disorder that can cause deformities
in 2012 gabrielle and his parents filed
a complaint with the quebec human rights
commission
and eventually the human rights tribunal
and won
ward was ordered to pay 35 thousand
dollars in damages to gabrielle
and seven thousand to his parents it
found the comments discriminatory
and that they infringed on gabrielle's
right to equality
in 2019 ward fought the judgment in
appeals court
it threw out the seven thousand dollars
for the parents but
upheld the thirty five thousand dollars
in damages for gabrielle
there was a lack of judgment in his in
his jokes
gabriel has argued ward's jokes affected
him made his life more difficult than it
already was
he was only 13 at the time and
struggling with his challenges he even
considered suicide
what i do is dark humor like i'm not i'm
not ray romano right ward talked about
the judgment on the joe rogan podcast
saying the courts shouldn't be judging
what's funny and what's not
but i was making fun of the fact that he
had become famous because everyone
thought he was dying and then he didn't
die
which is uh you know it's good for him
it's a dark joke that's all it is
there has been support for ward from
other comics the idea of courts ruling
on comedy some say could put a chill on
all artists now what's going to happen
is because of this precedent
a lot of comedians are going to be in a
lot of tv shows and a lot of film
writers are going to say well i'm not
sure i could say this anymore now
neither side has been willing to back
down throughout this entire ordeal it
will be heard by the supreme court
monday
having now stretched close to a decade
since it started
mike armstrong global news montreal
the duke and duchess of sussex have a
little something extra to celebrate this
valentine's day
a spokesperson for megan and harry
confirms they're expecting their second
child
later this year a photo of the couple
was released today it shows megan
cradling her bump
the new baby will be eighth in line to
the british throne
last year the duke and duchess stepped
back as senior royals
and moved to california coming up the
rumble in the rockies an
earthquake strikes a popular resort town
people in bath alberta were jolted by a
small earthquake last night
whatever color that you're doing
did you guys hear that the shake came as
a shock to this
online art class but there was no damage
in the resort town which is in the heart
of the rocky mountains
natural resources canada reported the
3.9 magnitude quake struck around 6 30
p.m local time
the epicenter was about six kilometers
north of banff
the tremors were also felt in canmore
which is about 26 kilometers away
it's a decent earthquake for that
area it's that there's a couple
earthquakes a year
along the rocky mountains and
this is not unusual to have an
earthquake but it certainly is
a bit larger
the u.s ice snow and cold temperatures
are stretching from washington
state to washington d.c near seattle the
snowfall has created a slick situation
on the roads
more than 200 crashes have been reported
in the region
and parts of the american deep south are
in a deep freeze right now
as you can see some roads and sidewalks
are completely
iced over a day after former u.s
president donald trump was acquitted in
his second impeachment trial
the battle may not be over seven
republican senators broke ranks to try
and convict trump
of inciting the january 6th capital riot
despite the not guilty verdict
the gop is at a crossroads with its own
political future
here's jennifer johnson one day after
former president donald trump was
acquitted on charges of inciting an
insurrection at the u.s capitol
the nation's top republican says this
could be just the beginning of trump's
problems
suggesting he may now face criminal
charges
president trump is still liable for
everything he did while he was in office
didn't get away with anything yet
mcconnell didn't vote to convict the
former president only seven republicans
did
along with 50 democrats 17 were needed
to reach the two-thirds majority
those who voted to convict say the
republican party is now at a crossroads
to keep standing behind trump or forge a
new path
i think has forced wanes the republican
party is more than just one person
many democrats say even without a
conviction the trial has done lasting
damage to the former president
those memories and those police officers
screams
will be forever etched in the memories
of americans
he is done but claiming victory there
are now calls from the republican
national committee for more fundraising
after the verdict trump wrote to
supporters saying i look forward to
continuing our incredible journey
together
but democrats are claiming victory too
after the most bipartisan
impeachment vote in u.s history 57
senators
including seven republicans chose
country over party considered the
evidence and reached the same conclusion
we did which was that
the president incited insurrection with
the trial over both sides will now
refocus on a country still reeling from
the covet 19 pandemic
millions still out of work and millions
more still unable to get vaccinated to
protect themselves
from a virus that has killed over 475
000 americans
already the variant that originated in
the uk has reached 39 states and
continues to spread
early data have demonstrated that is
around 40 to 50 percent more
transmissible already that means we're
likely to have more cases and more
deaths from this
democrats are anxious to get back to
work on president biden's 1.9 trillion
dollar
coven 19 relief package saying they will
pass the plan to help struggling
americans
with or without republican support
jennifer johnson
global news washington still ahead the
future of finance
is canada ready for a digital loony
imagine a digital loony becoming legal
tender
well that day is getting closer a recent
survey found most major banks are
considering some form of digital
currency
within the next six years three research
teams have produced proposals for the
bank of canada
as eric sorensen reports this could fuel
the digital economy
every day more canadians pay digitally
and fewer businesses need this
a cash drawer stuffed with bills
canadians are among the most cash-free
spenders in the world
so is it time for digital currency the
bank of canada isn't promoting the idea
but believes it needs to be ready
currency is a core part of the bank of
canada's mandate
for several years the bank of canada has
been analyzing what circumstances
might lead canada to decide to issue a
digital
currency the bank of canada is now
studying proposals from three sets of
university experts for a homegrown
digital currency
formulas for how to spend with the
anonymity of cash
without using cash it could work like
this
through an app on a cell phone a user
sets up a secure
e-wallet it's authenticated through a
government agency
and it's ready to go the merchant
establishes a digital transaction to
accept the funds
but a critical new step in between what
the u of t and york team calls a white
list
where the transaction is not only
authenticated but will ensure
customer information is not passed on
just
the money privacy is paramount we
believe that the canadian government has
an obligation to give people a way to
protect us for privacy
and give them in particular because
payments are so essential for commercial
interactions
the currency would require measures
against too much privacy
to prevent money laundering and tax
evasion and while cash payments are
becoming a smaller part of the economy
the central bank says it wouldn't
abandon communities not connected to
high-tech commerce
that means for one thing ensuring that
remote and marginalized communities are
not left out of
any new way of way to pay for goods and
services
the so-called cbdc wouldn't be a direct
counter to bitcoin
which is an investment currency rather
than a cash equivalent consumer currency
but canada cannot sit back say experts
as other countries like
china unveil digital currencies and
private enterprise cryptocurrencies such
as facebook's dm
are developed it's a matter of national
sovereignty
so i don't think the bank of canada or
any central bank of that matter
would like to outsource this process to
a third party
even if it is a domestic party land
alone a foreign one
only a central bank can guarantee
complete safety
and universal access and with public
interest
not profits as a top priority digital
currency won't be issued before
canadians in ottawa wanted
but when they do the bank of canada
wants to be ready to roll it out
eric sorensen global news toronto
beer lovers and historians pay attention
archaeologists in egypt have discovered
what could be one of the world's oldest
breweries
the 5 000 year old beer factory was
unearthed in the ancient city of
abidos near the nile river several units
were found housing dozens of pottery
basins used to heat grains and water
to produce beer it wasn't exactly for
good times though
evidence suggests the beer was used for
royal
burial rites up next a carousel in
estonia made with some
cold creativity
a nice carousel in estonia is enticing
people to get outdoors for valentine's
day and feel the love
a local man is behind the design he cut
into the thick ice to create the 12
meter circle and attached a boat engine
to get it to rotate
he says he simply wanted something to
keep his grandchildren entertained and
some days he takes his laptop
out on the ice to do some work
that's right it's valentine's day for
some it's a hallmark holiday
for others it's a time of romance but
this is no time to spread the love being
in a pandemic
so we turn to stuart reynolds known
online as brittlestar to talk about love
connections
in the age of wi-fi and zoom dates
romance and technology always find a way
to hook up
i remember back in 1993 a woman i worked
with went to meet a man she had met on
the internet
the internet in the early 90s no
uploaded pictures in those days
while i was using the internet for what
it was intended
looking up the lyrics to inform her by
snow
they probably just sent dirty emoticons
back and forth
or ascii nudes you know like typewriter
art that just uses letters and
punctuation to make a picture
what are all those commas
total weirdos why couldn't they just
meet in a bar and find out if they're
compatible by partaking in a little
lip lock roulette that's where you open
mouth kiss a stranger and you don't know
what you're gonna get
but how things have changed these days
i can't imagine even agreeing to meet
with anyone without googling them first
let alone a potential romantic partner
uh yeah if we're gonna be intimate and
vulnerable with each other
i'm going to need to know the last four
places you worked and i will be
thoroughly scouring your social media
for incriminating posts
even though we can't get together in
person that easily currently
i would think that it's actually better
the way it is these days
date going terribly close your laptop
person turns out to be a creep boom
blocked
and with physical distance no longer
playing a role
i think you can slowly get to know
someone without panicking that
they're about to suddenly turn the
lights up after last call
romance is difficult though and it
always has been a roll of the dice
these days it just happens to also be a
chance click or a
swipe these days
love should be in the air you know like
wi-fi
once only in certain places but now
available pretty much everywhere
and that is global national for this
sunday i'm robin gill
we leave you tonight with a birthday
wish for a woman who served a long time
in politics i never expected
to be recognized on my 100th birthday
people in mississauga ontario did a
surprise birthday drive-by to greet
hazel mccallion on her 100th birthday
nicknamed hurricane hazel and known for
being direct and outspoken
she served as mayor of mississauga for
36 years before stepping down
in 2014. thanks for watching have a
great night
you